[Music]
um
okay welcome everybody
to the August one
infrastructure meeting
welcome to those streaming in from mum
right we're going to start off the
meeting with the apologies and we have a
few we have Amir Clark councilor Arnold
councilor Campbell
counselor Sopo and ribbon can I
have someone please move those uh moved
Grant second to Darren put that all
those in favor
no one's zooming in uh there is no
public forum today
right we're going to start with the
minutes of the waste Advisory Group
uh from 26th of June
can I have someone move that thank you
grant thanks Trish put that all those in
favor
and then we have the minutes of the
infrastructure meeting from ask a couple
questions on those months yes you
certainly can sorry yeah so just
um on the bottom of page five the
ministry for environments presentation
yep can that be put in the resource
Library
but I'll be quite King down a lot of
them and I think we all should be having
a look at that
yeah that can certainly be done if we
have done that
um yeah so that was actually that's
actually a good point because it was
in the full minutes of the waste snap
meeting we had last Monday but it didn't
carry through no to here yeah and then
secondly sorry
um
reasoning for Waste landfill trend
where's the information coming on
so on page seven of bull box season
Chris consumers being post covered high
value plastic Volvo where's that
information coming from yes that is a
good question I asked I asked the same
question there is no I'm not sure where
the data comes for you know the
economics of it you mean well no just in
terms of you know is is that what is
actually happening is that where waste
increases are coming from or is that
just someone
framing it up or so it's tough enough of
um Aaron do you want to answer that
thank you chair if we're asking have we
got data that's backing that up within
wastenet no we don't
um what we're talking to is the trends
that we're being advised of nationally
and whether or not they fit with our
experience right so so do we think they
fit with their experience or we don't
know we do think that they fit with our
experience that our Trends are sitting
fairly similar to what we're seeing
across the country
actually I'm just looking at those
minutes from the meeting of the 26th of
June and I'm um a little bit
uncomfortable when I come down to
section 2 funding or foreign
self-pelletize a plant and I just wanted
to ask some questions my understanding
was that when we had our meeting here
that our team was going to go back to
that meeting and we were asking for the
eighty thousand dollars from the
allocation to come back to ICC
um and then I see that there was a
resolution made there
um and then in our next series of
minutes is a different outcome to what
we went to the table with in the first
place
so I guess where I'm feeling I'm feeling
quite uncomfortable actually
um
and I'm running along the lines of back
to what I originally asked some time ago
what is the long-term Strategic Benefit
of us belonging to wastenet
when we're quite clear in our directive
about what this Council has requested
and it comes back and bite-sized I think
I think uh it'd be good to talk about
this one fortunately I think you've
jumped into PE
yeah I'm sorry I was like that's not a
very apology that yeah sorry that is not
in this matter it's very apologetic it
was looking yeah yeah so I've jumped a
thing very very soon I will save that
for the correct area yeah yeah no that's
all right
yes right as I said I apologize chapter
one
okay so you're right grant so
um
all done right it was on to the minutes
of the infrastructure committee uh July
11th
can I someone moved there true and
correctly thanks Grant thanks Darren put
that all those in favor all right that's
carried
move now to the
minutes from the public section of the
waste air committee meeting Herald last
Monday
for
yeah Mr chair Alex
singing the Trish yep we'll lose some
favor all right
let's carried that moves on to the
activities report and says it's quite
diverse this
um who would you like who's who would
like to tackle
um I'm happy to speak to it do you want
to start with the cleaning contract or
the uh look to be honest I'd take the
report as read in general I won't speak
to each item probably the key item that
I would like to speak to is the
steadstreet update because even now
that's a little bit out of date
um this was the information that we had
from environment Southland on that site
about 48 hours prior to the report going
out
um on Friday last week we were advised
that the next stages of traffic
management that were planned for the
site which environment Southland had
hoped would allow it that site to go
back to two lanes in early August is not
going to work the way they'd hoped which
means that now we will be well into
probably late September before that site
returns to two lanes
okay look I've I've got a question and I
spoke to Russell earlier today about it
um
it's regarding uh the management of the
actual traffic lights and how they're
put into operation now
I was of the understanding that it
picked times they were manned and then
being manned uh you had that human eye
over things that would work out there's
a lot of cars coming in in the morning
and there's not many going out so we're
going to run the lights that way and
clear the traffic but unfortunately this
morning
um
it was it was just on automatic and cars
were backed up at 8 30 all the way to
marama South
so that's a long way down the stair
Street and there was no one Manning it
Russell can I did you find out any
information about that or
thanks Mr Q I have spoken to the project
manager who's working on behalf of es
and they do have a person
who works or he guess who controls the
traffic signals during those Peak
periods but we couldn't necessarily
identify what occurred this morning but
they do have a physical person with a
control of that I guess looks at the
cues to minimize those cues so for some
for some reason it hasn't worked that
well this morning but my understanding
was there was someone on site um and
they did recall buses going through so
it's certainly a thing that they keep
keeping working on but the idea being is
that we have manual control During the
period from about 20 past seven in the
morning through to about nine o'clock
and then from mid afternoon about 3 30
through to close to Six so they do
control it a longer period to do that so
yeah well so this morning you had cars
from that that traffic light all the way
to memory of South and on the other side
heading into Toyota town there were two
cars
and yeah that's that's not really
operating correctly
what we do is I guess from council's
perspective it's a in a year site and we
continue to pass all of those issues
back onto them and continue to I guess
Monitor and check with them that they
are actually operating the site as best
they can to minimize the disruption to
the traffic they don't need to come in
and talk to us at all
I'm sure they will if you would like
them too but I think it's an operational
issue that we just need to keep them up
to speed and
um and and
The Wider public I guess that the things
that we do see are there's a little bit
of uh I guess the frustration from some
drivers who are choosing to not follow
the stoplight
and I guess that's a problem but my
understanding is the police have had
been in contact with the police and
they'll be monitoring the site so that's
a
thing for General people but you're
right there you just need to make sure
that that is minimized as best they can
during the during the time the Project's
operating no that's good sorry um just
darynx but Aaron do you want to go I was
just going to say I think In fairness to
environments Southland it's always going
to be a difficult site to manage stop go
traffic in a different way and you know
I think some mornings it's working
effectively and some mornings the
traffic's a bit different and it's not
working as well as it should and I guess
what I'd say to that is we envisioned
that when we were doing the steadstreet
work and that's why we went about it the
way we did with stead street with it
being a much bigger site this is a
smaller site but it's it's working well
some days but it is still encountering
some of those those problems on on other
days and I I don't know that there's a
Magic Bullet that the environment
Southland team will be able to do to
deal with that I think in response to
that though they say they're going to
have it manned during those big times
which makes sense and then like this
morning it wasn't manned then what do we
what do we do you know and we obviously
it works when it's manned
and it doesn't work
when it's on man I don't think this
morning was the first morning that
things would be backed up to marama Ave
at 8 30 it's happening reasonably
frequently yeah yeah okay Darren uh
question for Aaron thanks chair Aaron
did yes give a reason as to why we've
pushed out from early August to now late
September
date I guess what we'd say is you know
let's be a little bit flexible around
when in September
um but essentially it's around and
Russell will jump in if I get that wrong
they were hoping to be able to fit the
two lanes plus the cycleway in to that
area and what they've found is to keep
the cycleway open which needs to happen
as a requirement of coptum they're not
able to accommodate both of those Lanes
within the width
and make sure the site is safe while
they're trying to construct it yeah
right yeah just with that Aaron so we're
updating the public through comms around
that that finish date that's smooth
um what we're doing is passing on the
comms from environment Southland so
we're trying not to get ahead of them
and we're prompting them at times around
the comms
um but once a an update comes through
from them their comms team then we push
that out on our social media as well so
yeah same question another way so the
residents about the people that are
being affected they are aware of there's
been a change in the data of completion
so I don't believe that's been
communicated yet
I'm sorry hold up before Alex has
someone yeah
Russell you asking we can confirm that I
know that it was on social media over
the weekend that delay has been has
occurred from and it came out of a yes
as comms team I think yeah cool okay and
it was linked to our page I think as
well yeah yeah okay Alex
um thank you Mr chair I know it's
obviously an e site and the traffic
management is up to them they're telling
us it's manned it's not it's that kind
of thing The Wider public if they
haven't seen social media they're not
going to know that it's environment
Southland they're just going to see
roadworks and steadstream and
automatically default to the fact it's
our fault
is there not something that we can do to
expedite or apply pressure or man it
ourselves because or you know something
in the mornings in the evenings to make
that traffic flow faster
because it it's a community beta Federal
Community you know connectivity issue
rather than a site management issue as
well
I think in
contractors that they're using are the
contractors that we'd be using as well
um
I don't think that they're doing
anything particularly different to what
we would be
on a site things don't always go
perfectly and there are some days where
you don't get it right
so nothing we can do I I do think that
um you know they're they're providing
appropriate responsiveness when we go to
them with with questions
um and they are trying to change things
to make the site function better
um if not perfectly
I think it's about a question though
um you know if we if we know that man
being man makes it work and you've got
90 of vehicles coming in from Outer
Tower in the morning then it makes sense
to allow that to happen rather than an
automatic
system that lets 10 go each time you
know yeah so hopefully that is what
we're going to see
that's what they've been telling you
Mr chair I think that's we continue to
encourage them to actually operate in a
way that actually minimizes that
disruption and I've certainly
um be reading them and I think every
time I get contact from somebody I ran
their project manager so they know that
people are watching and asking that we
actually get it as right as we can but
certainly there are other periods of
time where there are some pressures but
equally I think people just need to also
we've spent it there a little while and
I guess the wider messages plan your
journey there is are there are
alternatives and I guess the use of Bay
Road
um is actually a really wise time
because you do get certainty of travel
so so we haven't had any feedback from
the airport where the queues come back
um I I struck it to Conan Street one
night
um but nothing directly no nothing from
the airport
people missing flights yeah well the Bay
Road options not actually that great
option yeah
I know that's being resolved and it may
be different now but it hasn't been up
till now it certainly has been a little
bit difficult with two sites operating
here
it's okay running out any
um further discussion on other aspects
of the activity report Darren just a
question for Russell while he's here
around the school speed management signs
Russell wins this tranche likely to be
completed for the seven scores we've got
left listed
the current tranches most most of the
fittings we're in so those signs will be
up in the next short time and we're sort
of trying to
um block them into each of the periods
just before the I guess the idea had
been to have them operating when the
school holidays returned so each term
we're going to roll out the next wave of
them across the city and I guess the
fortunate thing is we are reasonably
well Advanced to get those signs we have
them available and be able to start
installing them so we're well ahead of
many other cities in that space
yeah
thanks chair um I've got a few questions
so be with me um the laboratory report
it yeah they're minor
corrective actions is there anything
here that's material that we need to be
aware of no it was just a few minor
things around suggestions on paperwork
and record keeping nothing enough enough
to give us a an X just suggested
improvements and nothing that would
could lead to sort of an incident around
noon no not at all
um and then that obviously
recommendation that they make goes back
to Tomato Roi to give that formalized
certification yeah okay thank you the
double glazing project here how do we
decide that was the best project the
better off funding was there a
prioritization or was it
um I would perhaps might have to get
Michael to speak to that one because I
was on leave last year when it was
decided I understand there were a number
of projects that were put into the mix
um and then it was decided what um what
was achievable
um within the time frame and and best
outcome I understand Michael will
correct me if I'm wrong around how we
chose the glazing project for the better
off funding
okay
through yourself cheer um can you just
repeat repeat the question that you've
asked
how do we decide that the double glazing
project was the highest priority or the
best bank in terms of a bit of funding
and I'm probably thinking just to give
you a bit of around our well-beings what
was that
where we get the Beast return on any
social cultural wellbeing people are
doing that project yeah through yourself
chair look there was that was an
interesting
um process that led to us going for that
particular project it's fair to say that
we did a full exercise in relation to a
number of pieces of work that could go
through the better off funding
this one did go down to that it was
aligned with
um not only what we were wanting to
achieve in relation to improving our
housing stock but also aligned with what
monafina were wanting to do in relation
to supporting improving the state of
housing across and getting warm homes
so that was primarily what it was
because we already had other projects in
the toe with around increasing the stock
and with also healthy homes so this was
about complementing those and actually
what was shovel ready and that we could
actually get going as quick as possible
so it was primarily around what can we
actually get off the ground as quick as
possible and had some significant
significant value yeah in line with that
yeah great okay thank you it'd just be
good perhaps to see in future reports
you know how that talks to one of our
Pro you know one of their four
priorities within a long-term plan just
so that we can be
reassured I suppose that the Investments
we're making fit in with what we're
trying to achieve might be some feedback
um on the transport choices
um
again same question around the
priorities in particular referencing
point three around the pump track at
Aurora we had a discussion at I think
the last council meeting around was that
the best site for that in I've engaged a
few in the community around
that and having been to the opening of
the pump track at Bluff last weekend
a weekend before sorry
um you know that's an awesome resource
it'd be great to have it in the right
place in South City so I'll be
interested to know you know why I've
decided Aurora is the place I know there
was some explanation around available
land
the size of a pump tracks not that big
the community seems to think there's
other better sites for that so be
interested in the decision making
process around that or is that just
still up for decision it's not our
decision yeah it's being administered by
Healthy Families no no no no active
Southland no no this is actually we're
making an investment so it's not the
it's not the um Patrick that's moving
around Southland it's actually a we're
going to put a pump truck in South City
oh and sorry are you talking about the
temporary contract or the permanent one
that's ever posed for sale City okay so
that would be a separate process newbie
stream yeah yeah
Russell Russell obviously
Mr chair as part of our proposal to um
the uh to gain our funding we we propose
we work with active um
self them to actually look at I guess a
range of options for delivery of a
certain services and they had been they
had recommended to us as part of that
process that a pump tracker Aurora
college would be a resource that had
been being discussed for the um I guess
the southern part of our city
um within the school grounds they had
had some I guess had identified that as
a as a high potential site so that's
really why it was put on our list
through the proposal yeah so so Walker
kotahi decides where what our community
need is
um no that's it was part of our proposal
to them and they validated that they
they accepted their proposal doesn't
mean to say we couldn't change it but I
guess that's
um where we brought forward a proposal
seeking funding for all of those
projects as a package
in terms of the temporary locations I
think so Darren's point the temporary
locations are driven by active South
yeah I'm not it's not yeah are you
talking about when we're talking about a
permanent one in the South City and my
concerned
we haven't I'm not convinced that we've
actually understood what the community
need is or where there is best position
not just around a pump track but the
wider social benefit and that can be
gained for the community by having a
facility like that where families can
congregate and then you get additional
benefit or other service provision or
use because you've got it in the right
place and I'm not sure at Aurora that's
one that in terms of that permanent
location that's when we'd need to go
back to the parks team around because
that permanent pump track piece sits
within
um the community well-being side as
opposed to this piece that sits within
infrastructure and I'm just gonna have
Steve jump in yeah thanks I I think to
add to Russell's Point
um the location has been driven through
conversations with the community Through
active Southland and so there is a
degree of feedback that that location is
actually
um well suited the service and there is
a as a gap and so I think there is a
community need there counselor and so we
are being driven by that but if you
would want a bit more information I can
make sure our team can bring back a bit
of a verbal update through the activity
report next week around the degree of
feedback we've had
yeah well I I'd be quite Keen to see who
you've actually got feedback from
because I've gone and done some
consultation with community and the
feedback's very strong that it's
actually better to be somewhere else not
at Aurora and just simply for how it'll
be used and who will use it
because it's a pump track's not
something that high school kids are
going to use it's it's your younger kids
that are going to use it with your
scooters in you up to about your 14 15s
it's not yet 13's to 18 year olds
I think the other piece that I'd add is
that we obviously got some strong
feedback as I understand it around the
otatara pump track around it being in
the wrong place as well whilst it was
being developed but once it was actually
opened there was definitely a real
positive outcome for it so I suppose
some people will support some locations
and others will support other locations
as well so so yeah final question or
final sort of point is what I want to be
assured of is it's a it's it's not just
situating a pump trick it's actually
what's the
it's an investment we're making in South
City where is the best place to make
that investment not just for kids to use
and Family series but what what other
benefits can we get for that community
and then where's the right place so you
know that's the thing I think we need to
be really clear on
right any further any other comments or
questions in the activity report
crap yeah thanks
um great to see some progress Russell
won the um
Mill Road North bainfield Road I think I
think you know a lot of people have
probably seen the footage of that and
it's confronting so thank you for
pushing that to the top of their gender
and starting to get a resolution
and Mr chair it's one of those areas
that we've had concerns for a period of
time and we will continue to Monitor and
work on it because we certainly have
some
I guess some behaviors and some outcomes
at that intersection that are not very
very great at all and we need to find
ways to stop people I guess where
there's a stop sign the message has to
be you must stop your vehicle full stop
there is no but yeah when you see those
videos you realize that the consequence
of not can be huge yes so yeah thank you
for that okay right I just one question
on the uh school there are the signs
um now who controls when they are
actually activating site striking the
school holidays James Hargis telling me
this drop to 30k and it was school
holidays
that's a really good question Mr chair
um we do have they do operate from I
guess a website so the schools can they
are but they will be pre-programmed for
the calendar year so that they go on and
off so we don't actually lead them to
the Schools administration to run which
like our other signs that we've had up
we've often just had a like a remote
that they turn them on and off and it's
pretty hit and miss but we'll have them
programmed so they will be on specific
days and off when the yeah I know I was
just wondering it was it was quite clear
at school holidays and yet they were
flashing on 30ks some of the new signs
have even got some of the smarter things
so they do record speed on some of them
too so we can get information in future
data so right now excellent right
last call
um right
um we have three recommendations there
and to receive the report to note the I
ANZ outcome of the three Waters lab
audit and also note the interim steps
being done to
uh help solve the Mill Road North
Banfield Road fair weather Road
traffic issues remove that fresh
seconded pannier I'll put that all out
in favor
carried now can I have someone that's
into the public session can I have
someone please move if we go into public
exclusive
move Peter seconded Grant put that
allows in favor
thank you thank you for those who have
been streaming out